islington is one of london's richest
boroughs it's also in the top 10 percent
of the poorest areas in england
and in these communities they're keeping
a keen eye on the government's plans to
level up
because here they say they need
long-term help
welcome to the ring cross community
center
we've been here now for four years
and it was going to be knocked down and
built up for luxury apartments
here they do anything from feed the
homeless to find jobs for people it's
about opportunities this area as many
others is in need of support is in need
of leveling up to use the government's
yeah yeah are you seeing any evidence
of it
no
no no very little support very little
structure
or strategy strategic thinking
the government is spending 4.8 billion
pounds on leveling up 1.7 billion has
already been allocated to areas in need
islington isn't one of those areas but
perhaps it should be new data shared
exclusively with sky news casts
significant doubt on whether leveling up
money is going to the places that need
it most
in some areas the pandemic has made
existing inequalities worse
but in other areas it's actually created
new inequalities so places that were
doing well and maybe developing and
gentrifying have actually suffered a lot
during the pandemic it set them back a
long way
that
complicates things doesn't it when
you're trying to figure out
where to spend your money absolutely
because it creates a more complex
picture of the uk a lot of the
information that's used to make leveling
up decisions is actually from 2019 or
earlier is there not a concern or is
there not some truth in the fact that
leveling up seems so broad
so big
needs to achieve so much that actually
the risk is that it it doesn't achieve
much at all i think if the policy isn't
brought up to date with a real
understanding of the new picture of
local inequalities then then it's
possible it's not going to be as
effective as it should be if you can do
plumbing that would be perfect but
to be honest
i'm fine with anything else toboko has
been doing a string of temporary jobs
for the last few years but he really
wants something with a future he's the
kind of person the government's leveling
up agenda needs to help do you feel like
you're supported
[Applause]
i don't feel like i'm supported now but
it's like
now i'm having to do other jobs and now
like i'm having to get into other jobs
other careers that i didn't even want to
get into in the first place
the government says that funding has
been allocated according to need and to
areas right across the uk
councils have also been given an extra
12 billion pounds in funding to tackle
covid
but the full plans for levelling up will
not be published until the new year the
aim to bridge britain's deep divides a
puzzle no government has so far been
able to solve nick martin sky news is
linkedin